security i don't worry about my job but
i think i do a terrific job and if you
don't then you should write it because i
worked my butt off to get this team here
when i first got here no one picked us
to be anywhere
uh and again this year the same thing so
if that's how anyone feels write it and
i'm going to feel secure about it the
results face business it is but you
don't do it every year every time you're
wrong should you lose your job
no so uh it's the same thing all right
but listen if you believe that then go
with it i know how i know what i did
this year and i feel very good about
that but again if you believe that
hardware then you just run with it did
you
it's true clearly you put it on still
out
so
yeah i'll be here whatever makes this
team you know
um
whatever allows this team to continue to
grow and get better and do the things
necessary to win and compete at the
highest level james you said the ball
didn't get to you does the coach call
plays to try to get the ball to you nice
question